翻訳: Riaki Poništ
校正: Shoko Takaki
携帯を片手に
教えてもらった病院を目指す
田舎から出てきたばかりの
わたしにとっては
一人で松江の道を歩くことさえ
とても怖いこと
言われた通りの場所に 病院はあって
大きな扉を目の前に
お母さんの顔が 頭にふと浮かぶ
（ため息）
「これで 全部バレるんだ」
ため息を１つ つき
重い扉を 力いっぱい押して
病院の中へと入る
冷たい ひんやりとしたソファーで
自分の名前が呼ばれるを待つ間
「何てお母さんに言い訳しよう」
「何て伝えたら
不安にさせないで済むかな」
そんなことを
頭［の中］でグルグルと考える
診察室に通された わたしは
すべてをありのままに話した
どんなに食べても食べても
食べたい気持ちが止められないこと
止まらない過食衝動で
体重が一気に増えて
下剤を飲み出すようになったこと
体が下剤に慣れてしまう焦りから
飲む回数も量も増え
今では一度に 90粒の下剤を
毎日毎日飲んでいること
抱えきれなくなっていた現状と
初めて自分の秘密を誰かに話せた安心感で
次々に 言葉と涙が溢れてきて
ただただ 一方的に話をする
話を聴き終えた先生は
わたしの目をまっすぐ見て こう言った
「君は 摂食障害だね」
その時 初めて
そんな病気があることを知りました
それと同時に「異常な自分は
病気のせいだったからだよ」と
言ってもらえた気がして
どこか ほっとしたのを
今でも憶えています
この中に 高校生の方って
いらっしゃいますかね？
いらっしゃらないですかね？
あっ いらっしゃいましたね
皆さんも きょうだいだったり
ご家族の方で
高校生が もし いらっしゃったら
思い浮かべてみてください
先ほどのお話は
わたしが高校2年生の時のお話です
当時わたしは ここから歩いて
30分のところにある—
松江北高校に通う 女子高生でした
実は わたしは
松江市の出身ではなくて
船で２時間半先にある
隠岐の島というところで育ちました
４人姉妹の３番目として生まれ
歳が近い姉妹の影響か
とても負けず嫌いで
競争心が強い子供でした
特におじいちゃんと
おばあちゃんが大好きで
４姉妹の中で
一番愛される孫でいたいと
小さいころから 何事にも
一生懸命取り組んできました
そして 高校から親元を離れ
ここ松江市にやって来ました
高い勉強レベル
入学して すぐに選ばれた
部活のレギュラー
毎日の家事
一気に生活環境が変わって
できないことや
うまくいかないことに ぶつかりました
だけど できない自分が悔しくて
周りに知られたくなくて
もっともっと頑張れば
きっとできるようになると思って
立ち止まらなかったんです
できない自分への苛立ちや焦り
不安は膨らむばかりで
その時くらいから やけ食いを
するようになりました
きっと 食べることに集中して
そういう感情を
忘れたかったんだと思います
思春期だったこともあり
体重は一気に増えました
初めは 本当に軽いダイエットのつもりで
下剤を買いに行き
一粒 飲んでみたんです
数時間後には
お腹に痛みが走り
トイレから出た後に
体重計に乗ってみると
さっき食べて太った分の体重が
元に戻っていました
食べてしまった罪悪感や
太った醜い自分も
一緒にトイレに流れていった気がして
すごくスッキリしました
さっき食べたものが
体の外へ出ただけだと分かっていても
自分が一瞬で痩せられた気がして
すごく嬉しくなりました
食べたい気持ちは
日に日に増えていくばかりで
増えた体重を見ては 慌てて下剤を飲む
その繰り返しの毎日で
食べる量も 下剤の量も
どんどん増えて
一度に90粒の下剤を
飲むようになったころには
24時間続く腹痛で気絶をし
トイレの床で 朝を迎えることも
多くありました
体重が減れば
「自分は生きている価値がある」と思い
自分に自信が持てて
体重が増えれば
「自分は生きている価値がない」
と自分に自信をなくす
わたしは いつの間にか 自分の価値を
体重で決めるようになっていました
心も体も疲れきってしまって
結局不登校に―
この松江という場所は わたしにとって
ふるさとである以上に
苦しんだ場所として
記憶に残っています
そして 大学へ進学しました
わたしは高校時代
不登校だったせいで
「食べる、寝る、下剤」
の繰り返しに慣れてしまい
大学入学後も
自分の体重には 敏感でしたが
自分の身なりは
あんまり気にしてませんでした
そのため 大学でついたあだ名は
「ジャイアン」
お風呂に入らず寝るのは当たり前
朝 お風呂に入っても
家にドライヤーはないんで
濡れた髪のまま 自転車をこぎ
その風で 髪の毛を乾かしていました
雨でも 傘はささないし
つけている下着も
中学生から５年間 同じもの
夜中には いつも
コンビニで大量にごはんを買い
こたつで食べれば
片付けず そのまま寝る
起きたら こたつは汁だらけ
なんてことも よくありました
だから大学の友達は みんなキラキラしていて
「女子力高いな」と思いました
わたしとは どこか
遠いところにいる人たちで
わたしは
あんなふうにはなれない
だって 綺麗な人って
「綺麗になるセンス」があると思うんです
家が元々お金持ちだったり
親がすっごく綺麗好きだったり
野菜が好きで
脂っこいものが嫌いとか
本人も無理せず 息をするように
「綺麗に欠かせないこと」ができる人
一方わたしは
隠岐の島の田舎で育ち
親もそんな雰囲気さえありません
「そもそも 摂食障害だったくらいだから
わたしはどんなに頑張っても変われない」
「わたしには綺麗になるセンスがない」
そう思ったんです
だけど 大学の親友が
女子力アップのために
岩盤浴や美容院に行っているのを見て
「わたしは 綺麗になれは
しないかもしれないけど
綺麗な人がしている行動を 真似することなら
できるんじゃないかな」って思ったんです
いろんな人のSNSを見て回って
まずは 綺麗な人の真似をして
綺麗になった人のフリを
しようと思いました
お風呂にキャンドルを置いてみたり
読まないのに 雑誌を買っては
SNSにアップしたり
写真の撮り方だって
たくさん真似しました
自分の食事も 綺麗な人は
おしゃれなものを食べていると知り
食べる物を 高級品に変えるのは難しいからと
まずは見た目に
気をつけるようにしました
「何を食べるか」も
もちろん大事ですが
それより大事なのは
「どう食べるか」
食べるという行為は
ただ胃を満たすためのものでも
自分を傷つけるためのものでもない
目で見て 幸せな気持ちになり
よく噛んで味わう時間は
心にゆとりをもたせてくれる
食べることは
心の中を満たしてくれるものなんだと
考えるようになりました
「わたしは どんなに頑張って
綺麗な人のフリをしても
本物には なれない」
そう思う時だって
もちろん ありました
だけど フリをしていれば
いつかきっと 本物になれる
そう自分に言い聞かせて４年
実際に作った朝ごはんが
こちらです
［フリをし続けていれば、
きっといつか本物に。］
今では あんなに頑張って
真似していたことが
本当の自分の趣味になり
心から 楽しめています
そして もう１つ
嬉しいことがありました
過食の衝動を
減らすことができたんです
新しい口紅を口につけると
その口で過食をして
取れちゃうのが もったいなくて
その日だけは 過食の衝動を
我慢することができました
新しい服を着れば
外に出かけるのが楽しくなって
よく人に会うようになりました
美容院に行き 髪の毛が
明るい色に染まり さらさらになると
何だか気分がアガって
その日は 過食の原因になる
イライラが 起きなかったんです
下剤で痩せた３キロよりも
たった１つのピアスのほうが
たった１着の服のほうが
自分を好きになれる
そんなに自分を傷つけなくても
そんなに自分を苦しめなくても
毎日の何気ない生活の中で
楽しみながら 自分を
好きになれる方法は たくさんある
なりたい自分のふりをする
そんな小さな きっかけから
始まった行動が
当時のわたしに 大切なことを
教えてくれました
そして わたしは
大学を卒業しました
実は わたし高校の卒業式に
参加していません
高校３年生のとき
卒業できないと言われましたが
いろんな人の助けもあって
やっとの思いで 卒業の日を迎えたのに
「行かない」と
当時 意地を張ったわたしに
母親は 泣き叫びながら叱りました
あれから５年
人より１年多く
待たせてしまいましたが
卒業の日を お母さんに
見せることができました
勝手なワガママで
高校から 島を出て
家まで借りてもらったのに
結局不登校に—
できるだけ 家事の負担を減らして
勉強や部活に専念できるようにと
毎月 たくさん
振り込んでくれていたお金を
わたしは隠れて すべて
過食と下剤に使っていました
そんなわたしも
もう 社会人です
ちょっとずつ 恩返ししていきたいな
と思っています
わたしは今
摂食障害を完治しています
もちろん なりたい自分のふりをしただけで
完治したわけではありません
大学に入って 新しい環境になり
自分を一から始められたこと
好きな人ができて
その人に愛される上で
体重は関係ないと思えたこと
海外旅行や
新しい人たちとの出会いの中で
体重以外にも
目を向けられるようになったこと
「摂食障害を治したい」
そう思い続けた 小さな積み重ねで
わたしは 今日という日を
迎えられています
わたしには今
笑って「ごちそうさま」と言える
当たり前の毎日が ちゃんと訪れています
これが 今のわたしです
もちろん 今でもダイエットは
続けていますし
なりたい体形には
まだまだ届きません
自分の体に嫌気がさしたり
人と比較して
誰とも代わることのできない自分の体に
苦しくなったりすることもあります
もちろん 今でも不満は尽きませんが
それでも 今の自分は嫌いじゃありません
今なら胸を張って そう言えます
今までのわたしは 太っている自分を
自分の中からなくそうと
自分を傷つけ 苦しめる行為を
行なってきました
だけど 今のわたしは
嫌いな自分をなくすんじゃなくて
ネイルやアクセサリーといった装飾品
料理といった趣味、海外旅行の経験
そういう好きなものを
自分に取り入れることで
自分を好きになろうとしています
そうやって
コンプレックスや劣等感を
自分を変える前向きな
エネルギーに変えていける人でいたい
そんな思いを込めて
涙が流れていくと
花やお化粧品 服に代わり
自分を彩ってくれる「お守り」へと
変わっていく様子を
体に描いてもらいました
［自分の嫌いなところを、失くす。
自分に好きなものを、取り入れる。]
わたしは 自分の価値は
体重で決まると思ってい ました
［わたしの価値は、何キロですか？］
体重が減れば
「自分は生きている価値がある」と思い
自分に自信が持て
体重が増えれば
「自分は生きている価値がない」
と自分に自信をなくす
だけど その自信というのも
下剤や過度な運動といった［方法で］
自分を苦しめながら作り上げた
一瞬の脆いものでした
皆さんの価値は 何ですか？
［あなたの価値は、何◯◯ですか？］
偏差値ですか？
お金ですか？
今のわたしは 自分の価値を
いろんなもので 作っています
だからたとえ 何か１つがダメになったり
できていなくても
わたしの価値自体が
なくなることはありません
それを知っていることが
自分の自信になっています
自分の価値を
いろんなもので作っていく
それが わたしの自信の作り方
わたしは なりたい自分のふりをしていく中で
自分の価値を広げることができました
絵、歌、スポーツ
何だっていいんです
自分が好きなことを取り入れ
自分の価値を広げていくことが
わたしたちに 揺るぎない自信を
作ってくれます
わたしの価値は
体重計では測れません
だから わたしはこれからも
自分を彩ってくれる
おしゃれなものを身につけて
毎日を豊かに彩ってくれる
趣味や経験を増やしていくことで
重みのある人間になり
重みのある人生を
歩んでいきたいと思います
ご清聴いただき
ありがとうございました
（拍手）